and how many movies there are called
dopes not gonna light this one stands
out though dope so dope is a movie about
a kid named Malcolm he's a total nerd he
and his two friends they're 90s nerds
they look like they are from 1992 in
fact when this movie started I thought
it took place in 1992 and then I'm like
wait that's an iPhone what's happening
no it's modern day they just they just
love 90s culture their total nerds they
get picked on Malcolm just wants to go
to a good school because who comes from
a rough neighborhood
Inglewood yeah you remember what Tupac
said about Inglewood Inglewood always up
to no good
Tupac says Inglewood is always up to no
good we just you take his word for it
bad neighborhood but Malcolm wants to
break the cycle he wants to go to
Harvard he wants to make something of
himself he in the movie want to prove to
you that it doesn't matter where you
come from if you apply yourself you can
make it and then Malcolm and his friends
get wrapped up in an adventure that's
got its shenanigans certainly ensue in
this movie and I don't even know how to
describe the shenanigans in this movie
or the movie in general it's that unique
and I love unique I love unique movies I
love stand out movies I love fun movies
this movie is fun and it dark humor kind
of way the adventure in the humor kind
of line up with Quentin Tarantino almost
where you're like it's not a comedy it's
not really an adventure it's both but
it's dark but it's not always dark but I
got to talk about the main actor who
plays Malcolm in this movie shamekh more
dude is going places in life because he
was awesome in this movies like John
boyega from attack the block when you
watch it you're like you know I think
you're gonna go places in life hell you
might even be in a Star Wars movie and
he was so good as playing the nerd I
mean other than the fact that he is
exaggerated in the sense that he dresses
like it's 1992 in terms of his actions I
bought him as a nerd who's just trying
to get by in his day to day in a school
in the bad part of town in Los Angeles
and everyone in the movie was really
good the likable people were super
likable the dicks were super dick
there's one guy who's like this
corporate guy and he kind of has these
crazy eyes where you're like are you
supposed to have crazy eyes are you
overacting right now it kind of talks
like this and his foot in Jarah
particular I don't know if I was
supposed to be creeped out by him and he
kind of acted like that creepy uncle you
don't invite to birthday but I give
props to the man crew because they had
to be likable they had to be adventurous
and they had to
have comedic timing comedic timing is
necessary in dope here's how I break the
movie down it's going to sound weird but
this is really the best I can do it's
like the wire had none of the cop
element in it and then had sex was super
bad and then had a kid and that kid
would be dope yeah I'm kind of sad I
didn't see this movie before the weekend
cuz I could have told you to see this
instead of Ted too but instead you
thought Ted 2 was all you had I feel bad
about that I'm just I'm sorry guys in
the end dope is one of those movies that
I like more as time goes on I keep
thinking about it I love the dialogue I
love the characters it was a conflicting
message in this movie that I'll tell you
after I give the writing for this movie
so I'm just letting you know but I'm
gonna say dope is certainly worth
watching and I would buy dope on blu-ray
I'd love to see how its categorize
you're gonna find dope in like five
categories in your Netflix that's when
you know you found something worth
watching okay so the spoiler this is a
boiler alert for dope right here and I
found this a little conflicting it's one
of those things where it doesn't
compromise the experience but you do
have to back up and think about it and
go hey wait the message is a movie is it
doesn't matter where you come from if
you apply yourself you can make it and
Malcolm does make it through his
fortitude and selling drugs and
blackmail there's a part of me that
thinks that is contradictory to the
message they were going for originally
however above that there is the ultimate
life lesson of in life you got to play
the hand you're dealt and he is dealt
that hand so that's what he has to play
so again I really don't hold it against
movie but is something you just crosses
your mind alright guys so dope have you
seen it what did you think about it
there we thought comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you